alors le jeu gars club est sans rigoler
ils ont fait une installation
s'affaissant tant qu'on n'a pas fait une
installation comme ça alors merci à tous
je vous expliquer le jeu de la preuve
c'est très simple on va le faire d'abord
qu'elle et moi vous avez donc un pot de
peinture
voilà le regard comme ans commence avec
quelqu'un de la team comme ça tu vois je
peux venger le perdant adacore gagnant
cinéma vous prenez pour la démarrer tous
les deux caisses alors attention il ya
un côté où il ya rien les égalités mois
vous mettez vos mains vous choisissez et
vous me dites quelle main et bien sûr je
vous serai un bon jour d'apple d'avoir
besoin d'un peuple c'est ça ne se peut
le faire aussi faites vous plaisir jours
de la primaire mais attention c'est
parti
balla gaye boisé modèle à tanger pas
mourir les réglages je dois mettre une
main vous mettez à ma vous et moi je
vais choisir je vais choisir quelle main
je vais prendre les cas je prends cette
main d'accord
alalala pas l'appeler les prix cette
nana c'est vrai alors faites le mais
avec la flemme au fait on fait tout ça
c'est fini j'ai perdu ok j'ai perdu
voilà bien froide avant au moins à toi
prenez là que ma nature matriche de
magna non ce ne sera pas moi je pensais
qu'ils avaient droit triche jure que je
ne risquais ok je joue je le jure devant
tous les dieux je prends cette mal à
attendre vous avez changé vous n'avez
pris seul je prends c'est vraiment la
reconnaissance eu à nous la france est
la solution la connaissent la wii je ne
triche pas la classe et voilà mclead au
fresnoy
c'est parti en egypte on traînera magic
contre elle aura attendez vous pouvez
changer dépôt attention aux changes
dépôt à lisible elle a dû contrer n'aura
à lézignan foot on ne triche pas c'est
nerveux pas là allez on y va
c'est parti madjid contre et nohra
tu reprends alors vous prenez le cas les
images y soient d'ici ou même plus la
gueule oui choisi cette main je lis et
cette main choisi cette année
mr bien mon enovia battant dsk savarino
et gevrey nous en fait mais comment je
vais bouger et non au plus bouger si je
peux me permettre et non ça va super
bien
votre tenue alors non je n'en mets ta
bouche et je suis désolé c'est blues a
été nommé non je vous dis à m et ce
n'est pas dangereux
vincent l'épave est en feu dans les yeux
savoir c'est un jeu non mais je vous
jure c'est vrai défi c'était yeux oui la
ville va faire beau jour de la plèvre et
la plèvre attaque tu m'as dit bonjour de
la pub c'est au tombeau je pense que ça
va changer changer de changer le changer
attendez on va tout changer
ok le mois fait le mois fais toi plaisir
mais désolé j'en ai pas un singe voir
massacrer
je me sacrifie une époque est gamin on
aura albator avec honda l'addition alors
prenez lequel chanard homme gentil pas
voulu de ferme à tout prix
à droite
je le souhaitais
l affaire interne et gilles verdez
contre jean michel maire
allez-y gilles verdez contre jean du
seul maire je vais me martinez la gueule
je vais te dire alesis ailleurs j'ai un
message pour gilles verdez de l'offre de
l'ormeau ah oui mais tout à l'heure vous
le verrez tout à l'heure à l'asie et
contre gilles contrôlant michel
attention c'est parti à lens mais bien
malin tu as togo est alors allée
choisissez d'avoir vous savez quoi
j'en choisis moi oui main gauche ferme à
gauche laquelle ma gauche pour un
gaucher c'est l'argent je la récupère en
selle à bahia rien bravo à vous allez
avoir à gauche aussi ma gaule donc c'est
ça la csn a annoncé avant droite c'est
la tombe et non c'est cela il est vous
les triches élus en plus affichées oui
tu veux du bordel quoi pas si tu leur
dis venez faire la fête
non c'est mal
arrêtez ces balles c'est mal je vais
vous national je voudrais dire quelque
chose on va accueillir dans un instant
juste manqué non parce que ça rigolait
il ya quelqu'un je sais qu'à quelqu'un
qui revient de canne et une attelle
bonjour de la pieuvre
une équipe jeune anton équipe a du
boulot merci s contact
là
ok ok oh là là bas et où la cac et tout
de suite on accueille tout camille cau